foreign
[Music]
this is the observability for
troubleshooting optimization with open
Telemetry session
um real quick though I want to start
with just a quick like hand summary for
folks here how many of you are familiar
with open telemetry
how many of you are using open telemetry
all right how many of you are using logs
from open telemetry
how many people are using metrics from
open Telemetry awesome how many people
are using traces
very cool okay
awesome that's great yeah good to know
um so we'll introduce ourselves quick
I'm Josh saret I'm a technical lead at
Google Cloud I'm responsible for
observability and data collection I'm
also on the open Telemetry technical
committee so I contribute to it day to
day that's kind of what I do and I'm
Mike Kelly I'm the CEO at observe IQ and
at observe IQ we build we're the
creators of buying plane it's a
Telemetry pipeline orchestrates open
Telemetry agents and we also contribute
quite a bit to the open Telemetry
project
so uh today we're going to be walking
you through three things basically kind
of a what is a hotel so for half of you
that might be a little bit of refresher
the second is kind of major Winds of
adoption hotel that we've seen
um and then the third is kind of an
approach to adoption for how you can
kind of use it in your organization and
get started
um so since I know it sounds like a lot
of you already are familiar with open
Telemetry we'll keep some of this brief
but at a high level open Telemetry is
observability framework and it's
designed to create and manage your
Telemetry data and what that means is it
is a set of libraries sdks agents it has
the goal of of providing a single
solution for Gathering processing and
transmitting all of your Telemetry data
um and in the past that's been the a
challenging thing to solve because
you're stuck with a assortment of
different proprietary open source
solutions to do the same thing it really
was the industry coming together to
solve this uh and that's why it's been
something that is significant and that
we want to talk about
the other way
so
there are three things
we're going to talk about with open
Telemetry and there are this is a very
large project obviously but the three
kind of core pillars we're going to talk
about are the protocol
so this is you know well-defined
protocols specifications it's really the
the
um the base that everything else is
built on
and it's uh the standards that are
needed for collecting and processing the
data
the next is instrumentation so talking
about the sdks libraries that you use
within your own code Auto
instrumentation and others and then
finally the hotel collector this is the
The Collector or agent spender agnostic
it's what what does the the bulk of that
processing of data and can be used to
stream and create your Telemetry
pipelines within your environments
and then one last thing before we go
into the details because I think it you
know it's really important to understand
why
uh what problem is this solving right
and we think of this in a few there are
a few key areas a few big big challenges
that you run into with Telemetry
collection one is standardization and
simplification so that is something that
open Telemetry provides and it's
something that without it can be
extremely difficult and you know I
talked with a customer
um he's working in observability at a
very large financial institution and I
ask like I usually do at the beginning
you know what are you using for
observability in terms of platforms what
do you use for application monitoring
what do you use them for security and
his answer was all of it right and I
suspect that that is you know people in
this room know that feeling ideally we
want to consolidate tools we also
recognize that the reality is that
that's really challenging and the
problem is you know I think right now
there's a lot of focus on the
consolidation of tools how do we solve
it from that end but if you have a dozen
different solutions
frequently you have a dozen different
ways to to collect that data and process
it and transmit it and that is a very
difficult problem and that's one that
open Telemetry solves so standardizing
simplifying that is core
and then the next in and this is another
critical piece is that it's vendor
neutral right so a core goal of open
Telemetry from the very start was to
provide a vendor neutral open source
solution to Gathering data and that's
that's what it's done
um and last without without industry
support this isn't a solution that you
can really adopt in and count on and
this has open telemetry
you know it's a cncf project the second
largest behind kubernetes and it has the
the support of the vast majority of the
industry more and more platforms they
they either have exporters to support
data from open Telemetry or actually
have native support for open cylindry
protocols
yeah another thing I want to call out
here is you know with open Telemetry you
can keep your answer of I use all of the
vendors if you want that's totally fine
what this does is let you change that
answer as you wish going forward
I'm sure lots of people want to keep
everything right
uh so we're going to talk about the
protocol
um what's really important about the
protocol is that it's the foundation to
everything this is what gives you that
flexibility and this is what lets you
change uh your decision of your
observability technology over time is
that we have this lingua Franca of how
to communicate the data how to get it
from A to B
um there's a like three key parts of
this one is you know it's a unified
standard this is a standard that we
built
um and and we looked at existing
standards and kind of tried to uh blend
them together so for example we spent a
lot of time with the Prometheus
ecosystem guaranteeing that open
Telemetry metrics and Prometheus metrics
are compatible if you've seen recently
Prometheus adopted otlp for push-based
metrics so now a Prometheus server can
even ingest otlp as well that's because
we've spent so much time making sure
that this protocol will be the standard
and has pulled in all of these
organizations and ecosystems around
observability we delayed a good bit to
make sure that that was the case but
today the protocol is stable it's 1.0
and it has logs it has metrics it has
traces coming soon we hope it has
profiling
um the other thing about this is It's
correlated uh one of the very principled
opinions of open Telemetry is you should
be able to use whatever observability
data you have and use it in a correlated
way
as opposed to
um you know struggling to understand I
got this alert now how do I find my logs
right you should have a consistent set
of labels that are available across all
of them should have consistent ways of
migrating from one signal to the next
and the last bit is that it's stateless
the way that this should scale the way
that you should use this protocol
internally should match how you scale
your own systems generally stateless is
kind of a big deal you know for for
servers we understand how to use load
balancers that's a foundational kind of
core component of most systems so let's
make sure this protocol scale is the
same way you're used to scaling
and that's a key component of it we'll
talk about it more towards the end we
talk about deployment models but it
allows you to do things that you you
really couldn't otherwise
so now I'll talk just for a second about
the open Telemetry collector this is a
collector sometimes I'll I'll use that
interchangeably with an agent that's
designed to receive process and export
data
that's it but there's a lot there right
and it's for all of your metrics your
traces and logs events it's really
designed to handle all Telemetry data
it's also designed to be performant
it's designed with usability in mind
it's designed to be extensible either by
by you and your organizations or third
parties and it it removes the need to
have proprietary agents multiple agents
that you're managing it really should be
capable of replacing a lot of the agents
that you have in your environment
and I will say you know when we talk
about the performance usability and
extensibility if you go to open
telemetry.io you'll see that that is
right in the primary goals that the
entire team has agreed to
there are several components to the
hotel collector I'm just going to talk
about
The Big Three
because these are the core pieces that
allow you to ingest to process into
transmit one is receivers and a receiver
is is just a component in The Collector
that allows you to ingest data it could
be gathering logs it could be
scraping metrics from an application
like in a Apache server
um yeah it could be ingesting data from
otlp or from syslog or other standards
but the idea behind this is that you
should be able to collect all the data
that you need from common applications
there are over 90 official receivers
right now that's in the those are in the
hotel project and there are others
provided by Third parties you can build
your own and include them in your own
distribution of The Collector as well
once you have the data in
then you want to process it and and this
is optional but frequently this is where
you see a lot of benefit from open
telemetry
and processors just transform the data
just like it sounds but they include
things like adding metadata so maybe you
want to add additional labels or key
information as it flows through your
Telemetry pipeline it also allows you to
do things like redacting data so if you
want to remove identifiable information
right at the host you can do that
filtering batching these are all things
that you can do with with processors
and then finally once you've done all
that you've you've ingested you've
processed you need to send it somewhere
and that's what exporters are for and
again just like it sounds there are
exporters for all the common
observability platforms uh you can send
data to Google Cloud Kafka Cassandra
really I could name all the vendors and
they typically have an exporter
available to send data from open
Telemetry and I'll note that there is a
receiver for otlp and an exporter for
otlp the standard open Telemetry
protocol and that is critical for
chaining these collectors together so
you have a true Pipeline and you can
send the data in a standard format
so next we're going to talk about
instrumentation right so this is you
know collectors is how do I take data
that exists and get it from A to B
instrumentation is how do I make that
data to begin with right where do I get
my latency metrics where do I get my
network metrics where do those CPU disk
memory networks come in and there's
basically three sources that we that we
think about within open Telemetry right
the first is what we call external right
external would be if I'm using say a
Java application how many people here
use Java yeah awesome okay if you're
familiar with jmx it was this management
protocol right that was designed to
actually directly update values and we
started to
may be misuse the protocol for
observability where we will call this
and look at the values that were
available this management interface and
turn them into metrics open Telemetry
provides this in that collector as a
receiver it's a way for you to get data
and observable data that you have today
right Prometheus exporters if you're
familiar with the Prometheus Eco system
are what we would consider an external
kind of instrumentation right you run
them on the side of the thing you're
observing
the next type is automated right or and
this is kind of
um sometimes we call it auto magic right
this is where I can actually take a
process that was not originally
instrumented and I somehow manipulate it
so now it is generating the Telemetry
directly in open Telemetry we have a few
instances of this there is a Java agent
that you can run that will automatically
generate Telemetry there is one for net
for Python and JavaScript we call them
agents but really what they are is
before we run your python we do an
import where we inject a whole bunch of
instrumentation before and same with
node.js we'll inject a bunch of stuff
and generate signals there they support
a whole bunch of common Frameworks you
know flask for
um
uh python my bad and uh like express.js
for JavaScript for example those are
automatically supported you'll get
latency metrics that sort of thing out
of the box
um so that involves very little lift on
your part and the last is what we call
manual instrumentation and this is where
you need some developer to write code to
generate a signal
what we want to reserve this for a
little bit is that when you have to take
that level of effort it should be
important to your business right like
I'm going to track maybe how many
checkouts I have if I'm selling stuff or
I want to track something very specific
right I will have to manually go create
a metric and do that we have apis and
sdks for that but ideally you should
have instrumentation from the Frameworks
and of whatever open source you're using
IF where it's available and manuals
should be limited to things that are
very specific to your company if I have
a specific framework or whatever we
provide all three of those and that's
kind of how to view that space
okay so next up we're going to talk
about major wins of using open Telemetry
we're going to give you I think three
different demos of some different things
that we've done and kind of talk through
like why this is awesome or at least why
we think it's awesome
uh so the first piece and I I talked
about this a little bit already but I
think the big win from adopting open
Telemetry especially if you're able to
deploy this throughout your organization
is standardization and with
standardization comes the creation of a
data plane right if you have
proprietary instrumentation other open
source Solutions all mixed together you
really don't have that data plan it
becomes really challenging to do some of
the things that we're going to show you
but when you've standardized you have a
single system to learn one system to
deploy one system to maintain that by
itself is is a pretty significant win it
reduces complexity significant
especially as you scale out so in the
largest environments are the ones that
see the biggest benefit from this
it improves control of your data so
that's one of the big goals of open
Telemetry is to give you control of your
data
and that is something that you gain with
with the data plane and there's no
vendor lock-in right one of the the
great benefits once you have this in
place is the ability to add additional
destinations really easily so one of the
challenges that people run into is if
you want to add maybe you just want to
test out a new solution a new security
solution a new application monitoring
solution
for some organizations that is a heavy
lift and I've talked to folks that said
that's a six-month rollout for us we
need to reinstrument everything we need
to redeploy all of this if you have a a
true data plane it's a matter of
redirecting rerouting that data so
you've already you already have access
to it you own it you know we're just
sending it to a different destination
another example that would be say I have
I have a cloud deployment and I have an
on-prem deployment right and I have a
local observability solution for on-prem
but I want a global view of everything
well now I can route both places right I
can send what data I want globally
globally and I can keep what I want
locally locally so I can do both
so now we're going to talk a little bit
about
um a little bit about tracing and
optimization from open Telemetry so in
this example basically uh we we try to
create a
um an e-commerce site that does auctions
right and we're designing this using
microservices in gke autopilot and we
have a couple microservices running
um we have some user behavior that we're
looking at users are able to kind of
view items they're able to place bids on
available items they're able to create
new auctions and they're able to
finalize an auction and delete things so
what you'll see as we walk through this
demo is you'll see those kind of show up
as use cases that we'll see in traces
um but we were running into a problem as
we ran through this so
all right
all right so what you see here is the um
Google Cloud Trace API we're using that
one
um and uh you know obviously you can use
everything with open Telemetry but in
here you'll see uh just a summary of of
traces overall of like traces in the
past we're going to go into the trace
Explorer
what we see here
is a set of examples you know where a
user actually talked to uh us and we're
looking at the latency that occurred
that
um on the right here are kind of
attributes associated with with uh spans
and things where
um that tell us specifics to do
diagnostics on the left here we actually
see the latency of Individual Services
and calls if we look you can see there's
like git slash there's git slash actions
get slash check those are actually calls
HTTP calls to different microservices
the for
um and we can look at different ones of
these and kind of compare things what
I'm looking at right now is I'm noticing
that read Json which is an independent
span I've had for some reason is taking
a long time when we first were
developing this application we weren't
tracking how long Json reads were taking
and we had these big long holes in our
traces of like what the heck's happening
here so we started instrumenting our
code and adding new spans and we saw
that Json was taking forever so then
what we did was we created an experiment
where we tried different rejson
Frameworks and this is me actually
searching for those experimental spans
so we created uh one experiment called
read json1 one experiment called rejson2
and we have a a random Boolean generator
when a user comes in they get one or the
other and we're actually looking at live
traffic live traffic sorry it's a demo
um of uh the read json1 implementation
versus rejson2 and kind of evaluating
those two traces to see what's changed
to see if there's any other impact from
using a different implementation of Json
so here you can just see us doing some
filtering and looking for particular
spans and that sort of thing that was
generated by open Telemetry
um
so uh yeah right here you can see we're
looking for a really fast span at the
bottom of that graph and at the top
we're seeing a very high latency span uh
it turns out that you know generally we
saw all of One span at the bottom all of
One span at the top now you don't have
to do this by hand you can actually see
it right here under frequent Uris it
shows oh look read Json on average read
json1 is way slower than read json2
right so I can in individually look at
something and try to figure out why a
particular request was slow but I can
also see an aggregate and we learned
that holy moly the framework we used
their Json reading library is
ridiculously slow so now with this new
Improvement we ended up actually overall
improving the application
how many times have we found out that a
Json Library
is the culprit yeah
how many times has reading Json been
like the Major Performance bottleneck
system yes everyone's running into it
totally been there
um yeah so uh and a lot of people think
when they think of open Telemetry
because it's where it started they think
of traces but wanted to do another quick
demo that just gets into logs and
metrics and this is another sample
application storefront application it's
instrumented with open Telemetry
Gathering logs and metrics also has an
nginx load balancer uh postgres database
backend and we're just going to take a
look at
what this looks like I'm also so in this
case I'm using bind plane just to manage
those collectors so we'll see that at
the beginning
and so we have here
uh
is a collector configuration and this
just helps you visualize what we're
doing is we're Gathering log files from
our storefront API
we're also Gathering host metrics and
logs
and then we're Gathering metrics from
nginx as well
and then all that's being going through
some processors and we're sending that
to gcp or Google Cloud operations
you can see the amount of data that's
flowing through that
and then just uh
deposit
we have it in a few different instances
so in this case a small cluster of those
hosts that are running this could just
as easily be in kubernetes and then
within Google Cloud you can see those
those instances that are running
now
from Google Cloud operations and within
Google Cloud monitoring we're also
taking a look at things like status
codes latency by host latency by path
we're sending all the log metric and
Trace data through
um and what this allows us to do is and
this is a simplified example here but
we're going to create an alert we create
an alert and we're just looking for a
spike in 500s
right so to keep it simple 500 status
codes when we see a metric come in that
says we've seen a certain number of
these we're going to alert on that
and so I'm going to skip ahead a little
bit just so we see
what that looks like
okay
so
now we have the alert and what's really
nice about this we're keeping all the
data together we're sending it to Google
Cloud operations we can go in and look
at this alert that was generated from a
metric and Google Cloud operations
automatically combine or links that to
the logs that are being generated as
well
so we see the alert and now we want
context to help us troubleshoot
and so from here we can just click into
view logs
and what that's going to do is filter
down to that specific node that was uh
that was having the issue and it lets
you diagnose you can see when those
error logs started
we can go in and look at the the log
specifically
we see there's there are 500s that are
coming through
and then we also have some detailed
information on what the problem was and
in this case it was specifically this
node was running into issues connecting
to that back-end database
right so it lets you link this this
information together and that's one of
the things we can do when we pull
together all the signals and with this
we can do traces we can do metrics and
logs all together
and one of the benefits of using open
Telemetry is out of the box you get the
same set of labels between the three so
by default all the Telemetry will have a
consistent set of labels and then the
additional labels relevant to that
particular data Stream So if you want to
kind of look and do this correlated
Journey it's a lot easier to find and
see things another fun part is your logs
will have Trace IDs in them if you're
tracing and so you can actually search
for logs and traces together so in the
log Explorer you can actually put a
trace ID in and you'll get the list of
all the logs across all the servers to
do that root cause analysis that you
want
the last uh short demo we have here
there we go
so this is
something that I I love about open
Telemetry is the ability to gen to
create Pipelines
so I told you about receivers and
processors and exporters and the power
that you have with this you can you can
create a pipeline within a single
collector create a pipeline within
multiple but the idea here is that what
we want to do is is
enable the user to enrich your Telemetry
data to filter out data that you don't
need right so a lot of times you're
collecting something and maybe you just
want to remove that before it's sent to
a specific destination
allows you to do things like redacting
pii and then of course routing it
wherever it needs to go and that's
critical because once you have a data
plane like we're talking about you don't
want all the data going to every
destination and so we're going to Route
it wherever it needs to go
and so I'm showing an example here of uh
you know I'm managing a few hundred uh
open Telemetry agents I'm going to go
into a specific one or a few of these
and this is a configuration it's
Gathering data from Microsoft IIs
metrics and logs Gathering host metrics
and logs Gathering Windows events and
sending it to two different destinations
elasticsearch and Google Cloud
operations this is a pretty common
scenario
we can see how much data is flowing
through but what we want to do is to
start to add some processors
and in this case we're going to add some
some filtering so maybe with elastic we
only want to send those critical errors
so we have filters a lot of these are
for filtering down reducing data some of
this is for deleting attributes for
transforming adding attributes and even
you can add a custom processor in here
but in this case we're going to look at
filtering by severity
so the left side you see a sample
snapshot of the data that's flowing
through on the right side you see a
simulation of what it's going to look
like once this is applied
so in this case we've significantly
reduced the amount of data but we're
going to put in a couple more as well
with Windows events
a lot of times you know you you don't
want pii data uh leaving the host or
maybe leaving a network
and so we're going to filter out IP
addresses that are available in the that
are visible in the Raw data
so in this case we can say we want to
mask that out we have a lot of filters
that are predefined we're going to apply
that to logs specifically
and when we look at the output after the
fact
we'll see that that's masked and
anything any email addresses credit card
numbers those would also be masked
and one last filter
you know sometimes we don't need
full detail and we can say we're only
going to sample data right maybe it's a
random sampling and that's enough for
what we what we're looking for and so in
this case we're sampling it we're
dropping half of those logs randomly
and so we'll apply all of these and then
see the results
and I'm showing this in biplane
everything that I'm showing here can be
done directly within a open Telemetry
collector configuration
in this case what we're seeing is
you know in this case we've we've
filtered out pii data going through
events we've dropped about half of the
the data leaving IAS in terms of logs
and then we've reduced significantly the
the data that we're sending to elastic
and that's the control that you get with
with processors and something that we're
not going to talk about but connectors
as well
right so now we're going to talk about
basically ways to adopt open Telemetry
in your organization and kind of you
know from helping a lot of companies
adopt it and from working through it
like lessons we've learned a little bit
so uh
there's basically three steps right the
first thing is just to identify what you
have if you have every observability
product
it's important to kind of understand
that and then match it to open Telemetry
open Telemetry tries to give you the
ability to take what you have and pull
it into the open Telemetry ecosystem so
the open television collector those
receivers there's hundreds of them
there's ones for almost any protocol you
can imagine and there's a bunch provided
directly from vendors for a lot of their
protocols right and the idea is you
should be able to get that data into
open Telemetry and into that format and
start leveraging this this standard
protocol without having to fundamentally
change your workloads right so identify
what you have figure out how to pull it
in right the second thing is crafting
that Telemetry plane this is something
that you can take your time doing you
don't have to do it all at once you can
do the pieces that are most important to
you and and move them but you know
starting to move your data into the
standard protocol giving yourself that
ability to do this filter and enrichment
live right and building that plane so
that you have the control that you need
for your observability
um and then the last thing is you start
filling in gaps you started with what
you had
and now this is when you start to lift
and shift or replace you know I decide
that the observability I have is is
fundamentally missing say I want
distributed tracing I don't have it well
now I need to go start adding that
distributed tracing you know through my
system
um if I'm missing say at metric specific
to latency on a particular service I
figure out how to go add that as a new
type of instrumentation so that's where
you start getting that auto
instrumentation and that manual
instrumentation right filling in the
gaps of observability that you feel like
you don't have but first
you know start with what you have don't
just try to from scratch Cut and Run
that's not what this is designed around
this is designed to kind of take you
where you are migrate in yeah
and that's a good segue into the next
um which we'll talk about a couple
things one is deployment patterns and
then one is some suggestions or best
practices on how you might migrate to
open telemetry
um
so this is uh one of the simplest
deployment patterns not the simplest but
what I would say is this is the first
one that I would suggest anyone would
consider in their environments and
what's Happening Here is we've
instrumented an application with an SDK
so we're we're Gathering traces or logs
of metrics directly from within the
application
we're then sending that from otlp to a a
collector that's separate from that that
hosts that application and then the data
is processed and sent to the the
observability back end
um you know there's some pros to this
right it's really simple to get started
it's a great place to start there's a
clear mapping between that application
and The Collector
uh the cons are it's not as scalable as
some of the other options and it's not
not super flexible
but one thing you still can do with this
is you can fan out so you can you can
take this model and you can start to
send it to multiple destinations
so that's that's sort of the step one or
or phase one of deployment
the next is to actually uh deploy a
collector as an agent
so sometimes we'll talk about the
collector that's deployed on a host or
say in a cluster as an agent it can it's
operating locally so it can ingest logs
and metrics directly from that system
um it then is is going to do processing
you can do the processing and move that
off to the actual host itself or in the
collector that we would call a gateway
which is happening before it sends the
data along to the destination
um you know this is I think a great
pattern especially as you start to scale
out it does require that you're
deploying a new application or you do
have to deploy that collector to all of
the the hosts
now one thing one thing to call out
about this particular model of having
the two collectors that's rather
important for observability right that
local collector is only responsible for
getting data off the machine
and making sure that your application
can get data off of itself as quickly as
possible what's the most important
moment of observability when you're
crashing
so having something local to let you get
stuff off of the process as fast as you
possibly can is critical right and so
that's one of the benefits that you get
by having that local collector but it
should be minimal
right and then its job is just to do any
sort of local filtering and dropping
necessary for that machine and then get
it out the door
but it's it's about an error failure
zone right it's not about oh you know
it's more flexible necessarily it's
actually giving you better observability
when it's done well
the next in this is this comes back to
the statelessness of uh open something
otlp you know this we can easily scale
this out so when you have larger
environments if you're dealing with
larger amounts of telemetry data you
have high processing needs this the
hotel collectors can scale out easily
with the load balancer
you know if your volume is low this is
additional complexity that you may not
need
and then kind of the ideal and state the
way that that I think of it is once you
have this if you have a local collector
you have your gateway collectors these
start to string together and they can
chain together as needed so you can do
processing on your hotel collector
Gateway they can be a Gateway if you
have say secure environments and and you
really can only expose one collector as
the the endpoint that's going to send
data out
these can all sort of chain together and
then you really at this point you've
truly created a Telemetry pipeline a
data layer
yeah so now that you've seen kind of the
you know if you were to adopt open
television from scratch
now we're going to walk into okay what
if you're not I mean most of us aren't
right most of us already have
observability of something at least logs
okay let's look at how we take this and
adapt it now right with that start with
what you have
yeah that's that's the key thing that's
where a lot of people will get a lot of
folks get concerned and say well how do
we
migrate from what we have because we
already have a large existing deployment
we have proprietary agents
instrumentation
um and they are maybe tied one to one
with with the platforms that we're using
but we recommend that you do this in
stages right
and
ideally
this isn't always possible but if you
have a new application new deployments
that you're starting with this is a
great place to to get started with open
Telemetry you can deploy open Telemetry
in the architecture of the deployment
model that you were planning on and then
send the data to the same locations that
you were already expecting it to go
right so this is a great spot if you
don't have a green field application
available it's choosing what what is the
easiest in your environment and that can
be sometimes that's about the team
that's easiest to work with right that
they're the ones that want to try this
the most but starting with with one
piece and then
that that moves into phase two
and I think this is something that that
sometimes folks are surprised by but in
the vast majority of cases you can take
the instrumentation that you already
have installed
whether it's sdks proprietary sdks or it
could be a different agent
proprietary or open source you can
redirect that data and there is very
likely to be a receiver in open
Telemetry that will allow you to then
convert it to otlp
so if you start to shift those different
workloads
redirect them into your new open
Telemetry pipeline
you're getting a lot of the benefits
that you would see otherwise you just
don't have that same instrumentation at
the application Level
and then the the last phase is really
starting to decide what do we need to
replace and and like Josh mentioned you
know sometimes that's on a case-by-case
basis where you say
I need to fill in the gaps here I don't
have the visibility that I was hoping
for
um it's worth it to to switch to this
agent it's worth it to you know really
consolidate everything and make sure
that we are
consistent across all of our
environments
but I guess the the key Point here is I
want to make it clear that you don't
need to do everything at once and really
moving it moving through this in a
staged approach is what we recommend and
it gets you that same place but you can
do it over time
foreign